Warren Buffett was in front of a crowd
of college kids and he said so if you
could only have one character treat that
you'd look for in a spouse what would
you look for people like brains and
beauty or character loyalty right and
he's like you don't want any of that
stuff you know what you want low
expectations that's how you create a
marriage that lasts he was being
incredibly serious but also
tongue-in-cheek at the same time but I
think part of that process at least how
we approached it was that we were
probably the least Hollywood version of
a relationship it was very much like
does this make sense and I think because
of that approach big picture neither of
us came in expecting the other person to
save us I don't need you to make me
happy I prefer it but like I can
continue to live my life and the other
person can too then the expectations are
significantly lower the fact that Layla
never tried to change me and still
hasn't throughout our whole relationship
I think is one of the biggest reasons
why like you've been good because like I
resist anyone who tries to change me
very hard and so low expectations and
leading from values has been how we've
just used as our compass and then like
we accept the waxes and wanes that occur
during the natural shifts of time